plenty of big sports news out today
we're going from the ice now to the
field the stage is set for the las vegas
lights home game this saturday against
the tacoma defiance at cashman field
christian is live there this afternoon
brave in the heat
is this team ready christian
hey kirsten well the team is ready the
las vegas lights are prepared the las
vegas night
lights aren't ready and i mean it's
saturday right so
what better way to spend your saturday
to come out here and show some support
now i understand uh the team is going to
be out here on the field in the next
couple of minutes to get ready
and to kind of get those uh that energy
up and they're like i said there really
is no bad seat
out here at the cashman field take a
look at all these seats all around us
there are still
plenty of tickets for you to come out
here and show support you can get seats
up here on the seating bowl there's also
a pool which i understand is sold out
for this game but there are plenty other
games
so there is still space available now we
understand there's also an indoor
outdoor area
to check out this game and of course
there will be out on the field
beer gardens so the heat is really not
an
any type of excuse there really is no
bat seat here
at the cashman field now again this is
the first of 16 home games
they already played four games and
there's 32 games
total and the momentum only gets better
from here the team debuted back in
2018 and you will be hearing the cheers
for the very first time from all these
fans as
these uh folks are out here playing and
winning of course and what better way
than to help cheer the team on
is for this mascot here check this out
he is the cash the soccer rocker the
team's a mascot to help get the fans
ready and energized and i don't know
about you kirsten but let me tell you
he's the most interesting mascot here of
all of the sports and also joining me
out here
today is one of the players danny
mavoski also known as
moose talk to me a little bit about how
are you feeling i'm feeling good i'm
excited to play in front of you know a
home crowd and it's going to be a good
experience for sure
all right so talk to me a little bit
about the biggest challenge here for the
team on saturday
i think the biggest challenge is getting
our first win of the season you know so
far it's been a little tough playing
a rough stretch on the road of four
games so now we're gonna come home in
front of a good home crowd hopefully and
and get a win
all right and that wind is not going to
be uh determined at all by the heat
right because we have
some pretty uh like triple digit
temperatures but the energy here from
the fans from mascot
is obviously going to be cheering you
guys out exactly the energy and the
crowd will be on our side the sun will
be down i don't think heat will play too
much of a factor of it so it should be
good
all right thank you so much and best of
luck on saturday once again
the game starts at 7 30 on saturday
tickets still available